in this video we're going to do a bit of
a deep dive in classifying different
types of goods and before we even get
into the thick of things I'm gonna make
some definitions so the first definition
is that of a rival good now a rival good
one way to think about it is if one
person uses it it impairs the
possibility of another person using it
or it impairs the ability of another
person using it so one person one person
or party using it using it impairs or
oftentimes prevents another party
another person from using it or getting
the benefit using it and we're going to
talk a lot about some goods that are
rival goods versus non rival goods
now another related idea is that of
excludability
and as we'll see sometimes these things
go together but sometimes they aren't so
excludable excludable means that you
could stop someone from using it can
stop someone someone from using it you
can exclude them using it so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna set up a bit of a
matrix where on one axis I'm going to
think about whether something is a rival
good or not and then on another axis I'm
going to think about whether it's
excludable or not so let me just do a
big 2x2 matrix here so that it looks big
enough for me and then I said I would do
2x2 that looks like about half way I
always underestimate okay that looks
about half way and I will do it here as
well and so on this axis I'm gonna think
about whether something is a rival good
or not so rival good question mark this
row is it is a rival good this row is it
is not a rival good and then for the
columns I'm going to think about whether
something is an excludable good so x
Pluta Bowl excluding question mark
yes and no so let's start in this first
top left cell so what are examples of
things that are both excludable and
rival Goods pause this video and see if
you can think of any well actually many
of the things that we imagine buying or
using fall into this top-left category
things like a so let's say bananas
bananas are for sure excludable I could
prevent someone from taking my banana
you have to pay in order to have access
to a banana and it for sure is a rival
good if I have a banana especially if I
eat that banana well that's definitely
to impair your ability to eat that
banana another example is clothing it's
definitely a rival good if I'm wearing
this shirt it's going to be very
difficult for you to wear that shirt as
well and like bananas you can force
someone to pay money for that clothing
they're not just going to get as much
clothing as they want for free you could
think of housing you can exclude someone
from your house or from an arbitrary
house they have to pay for it or pay for
the rent and it's a rival good if one
person or one family is using a house it
definitely impairs the ability for
another family to use the house and we
could keep thinking of more and more
ideas in this top left in general goods
in this top left are called private
goods private private goods now let's
imagine going to things that are
excludable but maybe not as rival risks
and there's a really a large spectrum of
things and as we'll see in the future
and you could imagine some things are
kind of blurring the line or depends on
what context you're using it but one
example of something that is excludable
but is not necessarily a rival good that
one person using it doesn't prevent the
other person from using it in theory
something like satellite television
satellite satellite TV why is that
excludable well you can force someone to
pay to access satellite television only
if you have access to some type of a
device or some code you
be able to watch the signal but the
reason why it's not a rival good is you
have these satellites in space here's my
little satellite and it's beaming its
beaming the signal down to earth and in
theory if I'm receiving the signal here
and I'm watching satellite television it
doesn't impair someone else ability to
get to watch that satellite signal but
we have artificially made it scarce by
perhaps making people pay for that even
though everyone else everyone could use
it without impairing the ability for
anyone else to use it and so that's why
this category of goods is often called
artificially scarce good artificially
scarce the scarcity is artificially
happening because you're making it
excludable but it doesn't necessarily
have to another example could be
something like a private park if I go
buy a bunch of land and I landscape it
nicely I might say say that you have to
spend $1000 to get entry to that park
well that is very very exclusive and
I've come clearly excluding people from
that park but in theory if I go and
enjoy that park and if it's large enough
well it doesn't necessarily impair the
ability for someone else to him enjoy
the park as well now if if all of a
sudden thousands or millions of people
tried to enjoy the park then it might
become a little bit more arrival risk
now let's go on the other side things
that are not so excludable well if you
think about things that are rival Goods
but not excludable the classic example
here is fish stocks fish stocks we're
talking about fish stocks we're talking
about let's imagine some body of water
here and there are fish in this body of
water and let's say that everyone could
you can't exclude people from it so
anyone can go and stick their fishing
rod into this into this pond or into
this lake and get fish but the problem
is is that if I get a fish that's going
to make it hard for someone else to get
fish and you could imagine an extreme if
enough people are grabbing the fish it
is impairing the ability for other folks
to get fish and so this type of resource
or I used to say this type
of good is known as a common resource
common common resource and it's prone to
what is known as tragedy of the Commons
and we have a whole video on tragedy of
the Commons but the tragedy of a
comments which happens for common
resources is when every individual
person acts in their own best interests
they might say hey I'm just gonna get as
much fish as I need to support my family
I could even make a business out of it I
can sell it at the end of the day you
might do something that's not in the
common interest and it's actually not
even in your own personal interest long
term because if enough people fish in
the short term and get that benefit you
might deplete all the fish and they're
not able to reproduce and then at some
point there are no fish left so in the
medium to long run you have hurt
everyone including yourself so that
would be the tragedy of the Commons
which is typical for a lot of things
that are common resources another thing
that you could view as a common resource
is timber or wood that's on land that
anyone could access and a lot of cases
clean clean water fresh water I should
say non salt water fresh water now on
some level if there's a lot of folks
doing it it's definitely going to be
rivalries but if there's only one or two
people and you're at your source of
fresh water is huge well then it might
feel a little less rival or so once
again we can debate it might be under
different circumstances now last but not
least let's think about what are
examples of things that are neither
rival risks nor excludable and that
whole category is referred to as public
public goods pause this video and see if
you can think of any well one thing that
is often considered a public good is air
now you could debate at some extreme
level if the air is really used up or
something you might start to feel like
its rival risk but for most cases when
one person is breathing air it's not
impairing the ability for someone else
to use the air and it's very hard to
exclude someone from breathing people
just need to take a breath so it sits
out here in public goods you could
imagine something like national to
national defense if you are benefitting
from national defense because of
aircraft carriers and missile systems
and planes and the military that the
nation has does that exclude me your
neighbor from also benefitting from it
no and in fact it would be very
difficult to exclude you would have to
kick me out of the country for me to not
benefit from the National Defense so in
general we would consider it to be
non-excludable and then is it a rival
good well if you are feeling safe
because of national defense that doesn't
impair my ability to feel safe from
national defense so it's also a non
rival good at least in most general
circumstances so I would consider that a
public good as well now when we talk
about public goods there's the notion of
the free rider problem free rider and
that's because you can't exclude folks
from using it it's usually not in the
incentive of any entrepreneur to try to
make these public goods happen and so
this is typically the domain of
government and in general we're in
thinking about this whole column of
things that are non-excludable
this is a domain where the government
tries to get involved so so we don't
have the tragedy of the Commons with
fish stocks or timber or freshwater they
might put some regulation in or some
permitting process